Y'all got a girl talking about
how she doesn't do her husband's laundry
cause she's his wife, not his mom.
Hi, I'm Lisa.
I'm a stay at home mom
and I don't usually do my husband's laundry either,
but let's talk about this argument.
But it's funny that we're having this conversation
cause I did just throw in a load of my husband's laundry,
and it was the exception to the rule of not doing my husband's laundry.
So when I first got married,
I did my husband's laundry,
but he helped me fold like he did mine sometimes.
It was a mutual thing, kind of like what she was saying in her video.
As my duties grew as a stay at home mom with more kids,
with older kids, with more responsibilities,
I thankfully
have a husband who sees the labor that I put into the job that I do
and realize like
that's something he could be taking over.
He also now throws in towels or household stuff.
He does all the dishes. Like
we have split our domestic labor a huge amount
since adding kids to our plate.
And I think that's where this fundamental like conversation comes from.
It's what do you consider stay at home moms duty and what you don't?
And I would argue
anything that a grown adult in your household can take care of
should be taken off the stay at home moms plate.
And that actually goes for kids when they Start getting older too.
Believe it or not, my kids also do their own laundry.
My 9 and 8 year old. Not the two year old, obviously.
Does that mean I don't like
sometimes help them out throwing a load
if I notice their things getting full?
Of course not. I make sure that their stuff is done,
but I make sure it's done by making sure they can do it.
My husband's a grown man. He can do his own laundry.
Doesn't mean I won't help him out if I have an extra minute
or can do it.
But that's not under the wheelhouse of a stay at home moms
like expected repertoire of domestic labor.
Or at least it shouldn't be.
I do my own laundry. He usually does his.
If you are able and capable,
that shouldn't be a problem.